ACQUISITIONS GALORE:
Ever since Satya Nadella took over Microsoft
in early 2014, Microsoft has become the king
of acquisitions.
They basically buy everything in sight in
every sector you can think of, and they’ve
only gotten more and more risk on with time.
Mojang $2.5 billion.
LinkedIn $26.2 billion.
GitHub $7.5 billion.
ZeniMax $7.5 billion.
Nuance Communications $19.7 billion.
And most recently, Activitision Blizzard for
$68.7 billion.
And those are just the most notable acquisitions.
Microsoft has completed dozens upon dozens
of smallers acquisitions throughout the same
time period.
And let’s not forget about their investments
either.
Just last year, Microsoft agreed to invest
$10 billion into OpenAI.
As you can see, Microsoft has committed well
over a $140 billion into investments and acquisitions
over the past decade.
For perspective, Meta has spent roughly $25
billion on acquisitions through the same time
period.
Google has spent $16 billion, Amazon has spent
$30 billion, and Apple has only spent $6 billion.
In other words, Microsoft has nearly spent
more on acquisitions than all of their peers
combined times 2.
Their investments alone are literally enough
to be a Fortune 100 company itself.
Clearly, a gutsy move but this has often been
described as being the smart play.
It’s not like their peers aren’t investing
similar amounts of capital, it’s just that
they don’t invest as much into acquisitions
when maybe they should be.
For obvious reasons, buying highly established
multi deca billion companies is a lot safer
than betting a $100 billion on the Metaverse.
But, is it really?
Microsoft’s acquisitions have obviously
played out in their favor over the past decade
but that was during an everlasting bull market
where everything tech related was going up.
During downturns, however, having clear focus
on a few sectors and pinpoint precision over
your subsidiaries is critical.
And Microsoft’s massive holdings is basically
the exact opposite of that.
So, will Microsoft’s acquisition galore
eventually end up backfiring?
A CAUTIONARY TALE:
Likely the best example of a company failing
because it was too bloated is none other than
GE.
If you’re not familiar with GE, they were
an industrial giant that was once the largest
company in the world throughout much of the
2000s.
It was created by Thomas Edison in 1892 and
over the next century, they became involved
in everything under the sun.
From manufacturing kitchen appliances and
household electronics to building jet engines
and handing out loans.
And this evolution was largely thanks to a
man named Jack Welch or Neutron Jack.
Jack was a shrewd businessman that was basically
the embodiment of all of the worst parts of
capitalism.
For example, he was the creator of the infamous
rank and yank policy.
This is when you fire the bottom 10% of your
workforce every single year in order to constantly
keep everyone one their feet and progressing.
And while that might sound like a decent strategy
on paper, it usually just leads to a bunch
infighting, backstabbing, and office politics
instead of true forward progress.
GE leveraged this strategy for a full 20 years
between 1981 and 2001.
This is one of the key strategies that got
them to the top of the Fortune 500, and it
wasn’t till the 2010s that the effects of
this practice really started to shine through.
The reality was that GE’s workforce had
just become a soulless environment where people
only looked out for themselves.
As such, when the company started falling,
most of their employees just jumped ship and
the ones that remained didn’t really unite
together, making the crash even more painful.
And you know why this practice is especially
relevant?
Well, Microsoft leveraged the same strategy
under Steve Ballmer’s leadership between
2000 and 2014.
And that was just the most notable example.
Steve very much looked up to Jack Welch and
tried to emulate his management style as much
as possible, leading to ominously similar
workforces.
Within the tech world, Microsoft has been
somewhat of a dark horse ever since the 2000s.
They’ve grown from hundreds of billions
of dollars to trillions of dollars while scaling
their workforce from tens of thousands to
hundreds of thousands.
But despite this insane growth, no one is
particularly excited about Microsoft, I mean
other than Steve Ballmer, but let’s just
say he’s biased.
Seriously though, when was the last time that
people were truly excited about a Microsoft
product?
Their partnership with ChatGPT was likely
the highlight of their last 24 years of business.
Conversely, Apple is able to reintroduce the
iPhone 14 with a new name and garner 37 million
views on YouTube alone.
It’s the same thing with even Google and
Facebook.
While these companies get loads of criticism,
people still pay attention to them.
Just recently, Threads was able to surpass
100 million downloads right after launch.
With Microsoft on the other hand, even people
who are usually in the know often don’t
know that they own GitHub or LinkedIn.
The only other tech giant who’s workforce
is similar in nature is Amazon which is not
surprising given that Jeff Bezos is also a
fan of Jack Welch.
In fact, they still do rank and yanking to
this day.
But anyway, whether it be consumers, employees,
or even investors, dealings with Microsoft
are largely just transactional.
You could say that Microsoft is basically
the definition of soulless corporation.
This has been great for flying under the radar,
minimizing press coverage, and yeeting regulation.
But, this also brings into question how well
the company can assemble and unite during
a downturn.
If GE was anything to go by, it’s likely
that Microsoft’s employees, leadership,
and investors would also just bail as soon
as things got tough.
In fact, they’d probably be praised by the
friends and family and even the news for seeing
the writing on the wall and jumping ship before
it was too late.
But, soulessness is only the first similarity
between Microsoft and GE.
If we look behind the scenes, things get quite
unsettling.
UNSETTLING SIMILARITIES:
There’s hundreds and hundreds of articles
and case studies out there about why GE failed
but I don’t think any of them are as relevant
as the case study written by Bill Gates himself.
And honestly, his article is quite unnerving.
I feel that you could go through the entire
piece and replace every mention of GE with
Microsoft and it would fit perfectly.
For example, Gates could’ve said “Microsoft’s
fall is not the result of innovators developing
a better OS or cloud infrastructure.
It’s also not a case of outright fraud,
like Enron.
It’s a textbook case of mismanagement of
an overly complex business.”
“Only a few people saw it coming.
I wish I could tell you that I was one of
them, but I was just as surprised as most
people.”
“That’s why I was eager to read Lights
Out: Pride, Delusion, and the Fall of Microsoft.”
“Gryta and Mann gave me the detailed insight
I was looking for into the culture, decisions,
and accounting that eventually caught up to
Microsoft in a gigantic way.”
As you can see, GE didn’t fall because of
some sort of monumental event like fraud or
being out innovated or even the 2008 financial
crisis.
Instead, they slowly rotted from the inside
out, something that no one really spotted
until it was too late.
But looking back, 2 red flags regarding GE’s
downfall become apparent in retrospect starting
with how GE’s management team always made
the numbers.
Quarter after quarter and year after year,
GE consistently posted increasing revenue
and profit just like Microsoft has since Satya
tookover.
Growth in itself is not a bad thing but such
consistent growth can often be a red flag
for more nefarious activities.
Not necessarily illegal activites per se but
activities that ensure growth no matter the
cost.
GE for example, would often sell assets to
friends in order to boost quarterly profits.
Bill Gates of course goes on to claim that
Microsoft would never do anything to artificially
boost profits, but I’m not sure that we
can necessarily take him at his word.
Last year for example, Microsoft skipped salary
increases despite high inflation due to quote
on quote economic uncertainties.
Now, this would be completely understandable
if Microsoft was at breakeven or burning money.
But Microsoft would actually go on to post
record profits of $77 billion that same year.
This means that the only reason Microsoft
didn’t go through with salary increases
was to make Wall Street happy.
To meet the numbers no matter the cost and
put on a success theater despite the economic
headwinds just like GE.
Microsoft wants to be the company that performs
no matter the situation when in reality, that’s
simply not naturally possible leading to questionable
choices.
This brings us into Bill Gates’ second takeaway
about GE which again can largely be applied
to Microsoft.
My second big takeaway from Lights Out is
that Microsoft didn’t have the right talent
and systems to bundle together a dizzying
array of unrelated businesses—including
cloud infrastructure, social media, AI, tech
hardware, gaming, video conferencing, and
consumer software —and manage them well.
Investors bought into the notion that the
company’s hands off management style was
better at managing things than anyone else,
and that Microsoft could produce consistent
profits even in highly cyclical markets.
And Microsoft successfully persuaded people
that its empathetic leader Satya could avoid
the pitfalls that had tripped up big conglomerates
in the past.
In reality, Satya often didn’t understand
the specifics of the industries they had to
manage and couldn’t navigate trends in their
industries.
For example, the authors make the case that
VP Phil Spencer didn’t have a good handle
on its huge gaming unit, Microsoft Gaming
which gambled tens of billions on acquisitions,
sold money losing consoles, and wasn’t even
close to Nintendo or Sony.
“Making money from [Microsoft Gaming] seemed
shockingly simple to him at first, as they
had already done it with Minecraft, but consistently
satisfying a wide range of gamers was treacherously
complex, and deep risks lurked there and were
not always easily spotted in the quarterly
profits and losses”.
One former Microsoft executive told the authors
that “Spencer struggled with basic concepts—the
difference between the needs of console and
mobile gamers, for instance, which was fundamental
to a lending operation like Microsoft Gaming.”
This dynamic was not confined to Spencer.
It was rampant throughout the company’s
top ranks.
As a result, the ability of top executives
to understand what was really going on was
quite limited.
The only people who could actually dig down
into the numbers and see what was going on
were in finance.
And as I mentioned above, the finance people
didn’t have much incentive to bring negative
news to Satya or Spencer.
As you can see, the parallels between GE and
Microsoft are stunning which brings us into
the question of what does this all mean.
IS THIS TIME DIFFERENT?:
As most of you probably know, we’ve mainly
covered Microsoft from a positive light over
the past year.
And in the end, that is still the prevailing
conlusion.
Microsoft is still killing it and though these
shortfalls may eventually catch up with them,
it’s not exactly the greatest idea to bet
on that because you never know how long that
could take to play out.
After all, GE was on top for decades before
they crumbled.
So, Microsoft could easily continue growing
for another decade before cracks start to
show.
And in the investing world, the trend is always
your friend until it’s not.
But, this does bring up the question of whether
this is how Microsoft will eventually fade
away.
In the past, we’ve seen massive anti trust
lawsuits, terrible consumer sentiment, and
over a decade of stagnation.
But maybe in the end, it will just be Microsoft’s
own raw weight that sinks them into the ground.
Of course, the prevailing theory is that given
Microsoft’s hands off management style,
they’re subsidiaries are rather quick and
nimble in their own right thus making the
entire company quick and nimble.
But, even if that is the case today and Satya
truly is a super star, will this always be
the case with Microsoft?
Will they always be one step ahead of the
pitfalls of massive bloated corporations or
has Microsoft just spent $141 billion on a
ticking time bomb.
Only time will tell.
Over the next decade, Microsoft will not only
have to step up to the plate in regards to
management but they’ll also have to address
the concern of market saturation just like
all of their tech peers.
Check out this video to learn more.